that's me what's your job here when I
want to prove them wrong are you pretty
I could talk to you about the whole gun
issue do you think it's a little
dangerous handing out guns in a bank I'd
spotted an ad in the local Michigan
paper that said if you opened an account
in North Country bank the bank would
give you a gun you say anything to me
I'll shoot you I sleep with a 44 Magnum
under my pillow
come on well the first thing we want to
do is thank you well I'm afraid we don't
agree on on that anybody any medication
right now in the promising
Wow how did this all begin where did the
HMO start Iowa America to have the
finest health care in the world
and I want every American to be able to
have that care putting its it what is
the message to the American worker
that if they come here and work hard and
do well and because of their hard work
the company does well their reward is
unemployment
we were told yesterday that I want the
people of Flint who would like to work
to come here and stand in front a City
Hall I'll have my film crew here dress
warm and we'll make a video my job I
want our job span very impressive I'm
gonna just plant the American flag right
here in your living room USA yeah